en france nous ne sommes plus qu'à cinq
jours du premier tour des élections
municipales et le modem lève un peu le
voile sur sa stratégie pour le second
tour il est question d'un éventuel
partenariat avec le ps mais sans
domination ni soumission à paris
marielle de sarnez a laissé en tant qu
elle se sentait déjà plus proche de
bertrand delanoë
helen hughes arnaud auguste voilà celle
qui pourrait jouer les trouble fête à
paris marielle de sarnez crédité de 11%
des voix dans les sondages
de quoi se maintenir au second tour dans
certains arrondissements
à moins de trouver un terrain d'entente
d'ores et déjà la candidate du modem
affiche ses préférences
est-ce que je me sente suis senti plus
proche de la gestion de bertrand delanoë
que de jean tiberi ma réponse elle est
sans ambiguïté nous avons été le
mouvement démocrate à l'hôtel de ville
plus proche de bertrand delanoë il ya
beaucoup de choses que nous avons
approuvé
alors quand la candidate du modem fait
une offre de partenariat pour le second
tour elle ne cite personne mais chacun
comprend à qui elle s'adresse
partenaires lui nous y sommes prêts
solidaires oui la solidarité dans
l'action est nécessaire mais soumis non
par scanner de l'ump alain juppé à
bordeaux du socialiste françois rebsamen
à dijon le modem s'adapte à chaque
situation locale
on peut travailler ensemble parce que
c'est pour le service de la ville et
même c'est mieux qu'on n'ait pas les
mêmes étiquettes et les mêmes idées
parce que le pluralisme c'est mieux que
le secteur ait un seul objectif faire le
plein des voix dimanche pour aborder en
force
les discussions qui s'ouvriront dès
lundi avec bertrand delanoë est bon